I had thought about adopting since I was
a teenager I remember thinking like no
child should ever grow up in an
orphanage the difference between growing
up with a family versus growing up
without a family changes the course of a
human beings life
to become adoptive parents there's a
major process of interviews of
background checks of making sure your
home is safe for your children
I remember a social worker saying to me
look we want these kids to have families
and we're trying to opt you in not opt
you out so it's not that they're looking
for people with perfect lives they're
looking for people who are committed to
helping a child
the first thing we did we went down then
I was essentially see if this would be
the sort of place we would want to adopt
fraud as we got to know the director and
she introduced us to this little boy
named Kim BAE and said I think I know
who you guys you know need to meet and I
distinctly remember it was nap time and
so we walked around the corner into his
bedroom when he's laying in his crib and
he's laying on his back wide-awake this
little guy huge smile on his face I kid
you not just this beaming smile on his
face and just kind of quiet and looking
up at us and just you're just just kind
of beaming this sense of baby joy we're
like what kid exudes this kind of
positive energy she's like this is your
little guy like oh my god you're right
this is our son when you birth a child
you meet the child that day and it's
this beautiful moment and then you go
home and you have the child with you but
in this case we meet the child and it's
beautiful and we're excited and then we
go home and he still lives somewhere
else that was really difficult and you
know then we go home and we just
continue submitting paperwork we had to
go down for visits sometimes just to
sign things in a courthouse I was really
just down there for a casual visit I was
just checking on paperwork getting to
hang out with kambei a little bit and
the earthquake happened and it was it
was insane it was like it was like being
on a blanket that someone was trying to
shake off we survived we were all okay
many people in the country did not fare
as well it was a really devastating day
for their country he and the other
orphans were literally sleeping on the
ground for dry boy was the most
difficult aspect of that adoption we
weren't really sure what was going to
happen to him we weren't really sure
what would happen with the adoption
I really became dedicated to trying to
get our son and all of the kids that
were in the same situation home to their
families because there were hundreds of
children in the same scenario who had
adoptions approved and were literally
just waiting on a signature to be able
to come home to their families I started
working with some of our state
representatives and advocating with them
and with the Haitian government to
figure out a plan to grant humanitarian
parole to these kids the ones who were
already matched the ones whose paperwork
was just you know waiting for someone to
approve it and a week later through a
partnership with the US government and a
Haitian government they did grant
humanitarian parole and refugee status
for those children it was actually a
bill in Congress that was passed called
help for Haiti and it granted
humanitarian parole for I believe 800
children who were in situations like our
Sun can bake hopped onto a military jet
with all the other orphans and flown to
the US without us I was on the airplane
to Orlando found out that he was there
at a different Airport so somehow got
over to the other airport
finally at 1:00 in the morning 2:00 in
the morning they started bringing one or
two kids out at a time so at this point
it's been three years since I first met
Kimbe eventually somebody sees him
coming it says mark Kimba is coming out
and so I ran over to this gate area and
the officer who carried him out hands
him to me and Kim be a just melts in my
arms it's he's exhausted emotionally
exhausted physically exhausted
physically and emotionally exhausted I
just want to embrace him and hold him
after all these years and after all this
trauma of the earthquake I'm just so
thankful that he was there and the
officer gave me this paper and said hang
in there congratulations it was very
affirming and wonderful and it took the
visa and held my son and just didn't
want to let him go
just held him for so long handbag had
three siblings at home that had been
waiting for years for him to come home
we got balloons and we got signs and we
had lots of family and friends who'd
been waiting as well finally you know we
see mark and Kambei coming out and the
kids just ran and hugged him and we were
all so excited to finally be together as
a family
Wow